this is nothing like it was when i
started driving you got these consoles
are like [ __ ] planes there was no
texting there was no nothing there was
none of that time period is this sounds
like
ages ago it was a late 1900s [ __ ]
i'm comedian ryan sickler and this is my
stepson derek crawford while we were on
quarantine class might have been out but
school was still in session all right
let's go
very serious business you have lives
especially this one in your literal
hands and feet
it was like an old country road and it
had an awesome hill to jump jumping them
yeah dude we jumped the [ __ ] out of them
oh
no hold on look at
look at aloha whoa
just heavy on the brakes i mean jesus
christ stay in your lane you're hurting
jerky with turns this is learner permit
so i have a question to ask you what was
one of your biggest like challenges when
you were first starting to drive when i
would change lanes to the left i would
drift to the right or if i was changing
to the right i would drift to the left
and i remember uh my dad screaming on
the beltway pull over and i was like i'm
not pulling over that was the biggest
one i would i'd [ __ ] that up all the
time not almost i remember we were
driving an indoor soccer game and almost
put us under an 18-wheeler and he was
screaming i was like i'm not gonna pull
over i'm just not
see i had driver's ed in high school
right uh-huh we had a teacher he didn't
take [ __ ] i remember one time he told a
kid in glasgow stop being an [ __ ] i
mean just so calm
made me laugh so hard
but he would take you out it was a chevy
corsica
and it had the brakes and stuff over
here so he'd take three kids out at a
time so you know death for anybody it
wasn't a good driver
and um my friend again eric snyder's
coming up a lot so he'd already had his
license he got it and he would drive
this big
chevy caprice
station wagon
and he would know when we were out doing
our hours after school and he would pull
up and he'd tailgate us he'd pull in
front and slam on the brakes we'd be
beeping around like come on snyder and
the teacher be like nah this is what you
want there's [ __ ] like this out
there this is what you want right here
let him tailgate you that that was what
he taught me he's like do not let the
pressure of somebody
you know yeah high beam or whatever if
you're doing the right thing let them go
around you let them move don't let them
pressure you to speed up cause an
accident but he would say it all this is
what you want [ __ ] just like this
right here they're out there all the
time and he pull up brake checkers and
[ __ ] and then i think he got a dui in
that car and
that was about a wrap on yeah
what's your gpa probably like a 2.6 and
you got two parents who love you yeah
and a stepmom and a stepdad and
everybody else you got a 2-6
yeah you got to love yourself i mean for
years i've been driving you to palmdale
and picking you up at your grandparents
place driving downtown to get you at the
train i'd drive out to upland and get
you and bring you
you got lucky bro you could have had a
real piece of [ __ ]
instead you got a pretty decent piece of
[ __ ]
yeah when i was 16 well you know we woke
up our dad was dead in his bed and then
it was it imagine waking up tomorrow
mom's gone
and your dad's already gone and it's
just you and your sisters and you gotta
get up every day and go to school i can
barely get up with them here you don't
what do you mean barely you don't get up
you don't get up you got to be told to
go to school you'll be told to brush
your teeth you got to be told to wipe
your butthole okay go right or left
right and then take it down to like
olympic and then make a right on
olympics
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you see that
guy didn't pay attention that ladies
walked across the street almost killed
her
you know there's road rage everywhere
but has there been
one like scenario that's just stood out
more than others yeah in baltimore one
time we were going to an indoor soccer
game and one guy in the car was four of
us that's the other thing when you're in
a car full of people
you're the mercy of what they do and
this guy gave the dude to finger and
they came chasing us or whatever and
i was like you're an idiot for parking
here they're gonna come and bust the
windows like they're not gonna do that
[ __ ] we went in and played the soccer
game came out all the windows were
busted out
[Laughter]
he's not his neck
[Music]
[Music]
you